c'est un problème criant en agriculture
le manque de relève
au canada quatre fermes sur cinq n'ont
pas de relève identifiés pour poursuivre
les opérations
mais alors que les embûches sont
nombreuses on n'a qu'à penser au court
des terres agricoles certains
choisissent tout de même de faire le
grand saut
alors qui sont ces jeunes agriculteurs
qui accepte le défi de nous nourrir et
pourquoi décident ils de renouveler les
générations
[Musique]
sauver celle appelés à renouveler les
générations en agriculture
arrive un peu bousculée par les attentes
des consommateurs les grands accords
commerciaux les normes sanitaires ou la
protection de l'environnement
ils joignent les rangs d'un groupe qui
fait face à d'énormes défis
[Musique]
on a confié la production d'aliments qui
est une responsabilité fondamentale de
responsabilité très importante
à moins d'un pour cent de la population
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais les jeunes de la relève ont voulu
le métier porté par une grande passion
c'est impossible de choisir ce métier
l'eau s'était pas passionné si t'es pas
amoureux de la production agricole c'est
impossible c'est trop difficile
depuis 2008 au québec près du tiers des
jeunes agriculteurs sont des femmes
hommes et femmes s'installent de plus en
plus âgée et instruit 80 2 % possèdent
un diplôme post secondaires et plus de
la moitié ont entre 35 et 39 ans
la relève est mieux outillé mais une
bonne part ne possèdera sans doute pas
la ferme de ses rêves une question
d'argent
la plus grande absence c'est toujours
l'accès à la ressource est la première
ressource et la terre de qualité la
valeur du prix des terres connu une
augmentation très importante depuis 15 à
20 ans
alors pour acquérir une entreprise
agricole il faut disposer d'un certain
capital parce qu'une entreprise agricole
ne peut pas supporter un endettement
équivalent à sa valeur marchande
les plus avantagés 56% sont ceux qui
reprennent la ferme familiale
plus de la moitié de ces entreprises
font dans le lait les oeufs et la
volaille
pour les autres qui n'ont pas cette
chance 9% achète une ferme déjà en
production mais d'une personne n'ayant
aucun lien familial
ce type de transfert est en baisse et
pour les autres dans une proportion
toujours en hausse de 35%
il se lance en agriculture en démarrant
une toute nouvelle entreprise depuis les
tout débuts
je vous dirais que comme un appel
naturelle envers la nature puis des fois
ils ont une façon de voir la culture un
peu différente de nos jeunes qui
viennent du milieu agricole
donc ça aide beaucoup les échanges
qu'ils ont les étudiants entre eux pour
faire avancer justement l'agriculture
[Musique]
parmi tous les jeunes de la relève 35%
des jeunes privés de mise de fonds
importante doivent louer leur actif les
jeunes s'établissent alors en régions
périphériques et organisent leur propre
mise en marché les produits ni chez les
produits de circuits courts c'est une
tendance tout d'un temps par leur
offrons pardon est définitivement ça va
continuer parce que le consommateur aime
les histoires du terroir le consommateur
aime le storytelling et je suis persuadé
qu'il ya encore énormément de potentiel
jour je prendre le propos de basse
au québec comme au pays la production
biologique est plus populaire dans les
fermes ayant une relève même élan pour
la vente directe aux consommateurs dans
près de 20 % des fermes ou pis alors
est-ce que la relève est prête
oui est-ce qu'il ya encore du potentiel
de développement des opportunités des
possibilités absolument au canada depuis
2006 la relève consacrent moins d'heures
par semaine à travailler à la ferme en
partie parce que près de la moitié
occupent un emploi à l'extérieur et
aussi pour vivre leur vie de famille ils
vont s'accorder plus de temps aux gens
ce qu'ils vont faire en sorte que ils
vont retrouver peut-être un peu plus de
2 bien light dans ce métier lol parce
que c'est un métier excessivement
exigeant très exigeant
[Musique]